whoever made the Tweet asking it how
many LTT backpacks would fit in a the
trunk of a Tesla or whatever the
question was oh I didn't see that
someone made that tweet on the LTT
handle oh that's really funny and it did
it
it looked up the dimensions of the LTD
backpack it looked up the dimensions of
the trunk and it figured it out how the
[__] did it do that ask it dude let's do
it live because I thought the dimensions
for the backpack are in picture form
searching searching for that now it's
searching backpack Dimensions shut up
look at this shapes and dimensions based
on some rough estimates I will try to
answer it's insane
that's actually nuts based on some
videos of the model y trunk shut up it
can fit about five to seven standard
Karen suitcases which have similar
dimensions and capacity holy which is
accurate that statement is real
that's
crazy look at this
how did this happen how did Bing no
offense Microsoft but how did Bing just
beat Google to the punch so dramatically
at something that's so important and so
core to their business
well that's actually a really good
reason for it so AI has been blowing up
lately both in the news and in real life
applications across a ton of Industries
so you know years ago it was only in
relatively small things like helping
doctors detect cancer early using
Advanced pattern recognition and then a
little bit more over the years with
things like autonomous vehicles but now
ai is everywhere it's it's creating
whole original pieces of art it's
holding conversations with humans all
over the place it's it seems like we've
just arrived at the beginning of the AI
age there's this chart that keeps
popping up that hits extra hard which is
the time to reach 100 million users and
you can see the faster and faster
adoption curves with these increasingly
disruptive new technologies so the
telephone took 75 years to hit this
Milestone 100 million number then the
mobile phone reached the same Mark in
just 16 years Netflix took only 10 years
and Twitter took six and Gmail only took
five Facebook in 48-ish months was
absolutely massive Instagram hit it in
just 30 months now Tick Tock we view as
this gigantic existential threat nine
months to 100 million users Chachi PT
two months I mean looking at numbers
like that like I buy it like it seems
almost obvious that we're clearly on the
precipice of something really really big
that's going to change everything so
seeing Microsoft at the Forefront of it
with this new Bing
shouldn't really be a surprise I mean
like people already like talking to
these chat Bots and asking it all sorts
of questions so it sort of feels natural
having this chatbot act as your co-pilot
for the web alongside search instead of
just a traditional search engine full of
links like that sounds pretty sick but
there is one thing that's going to
follow this conversational AI thing
everywhere it goes everywhere you see it
which is that sometimes
it's just wrong
sometimes it just says things that
aren't true because fundamentally the AI
doesn't know if it's telling the truth
or not it doesn't understand that like
that's not part of the model like what
we're seeing is it taking our inputs and
then creating outputs based on related
words that are most likely to go
together it's not forming a sentence
like humans do it's generating a new
sentence and so adding it to a search
engine like Bing it's scraping all these
relevant links and information and
synthesizing new sentences just based on
how it thinks things should be pieced
together it's not sentient it doesn't
understand what it's saying and so it's
definitely not fact checking itself so
we have to keep that in the back of our
mind through all of this right every
time you see a headline so it's really
interesting with these search engines
right because on one hand you have Bing
who has everything to gain and then on
the other hand you have Google who has
everything to lose I've had access to
this new Bing for a little bit it's a
limited preview before they push it live
to the rest of the world
I'm just been playing around with it
basically it adds this chat experience
alongside regular Bing it's essentially
the same experience as talking to chat
GPT but instead of being limited to a
fixed data set that cuts off at 2021
it'll pull from the entire current web
that Bing can scrape from so like I said
you can type in a question flip it over
to chat and it'll give you a sort of
nicely written summary that's
synthesized based on what it finds for
similar queries so if I ask it something
kind of simple like what's the average
lifespan of a cheetah in the wild it
gives me an answer right gives me a
convincing bunch of sentences it
actually gives me more information that
I asked for it tells me about cheetahs
in captivity too which makes it you know
feel very convincing it also gives
little footnotes and citations for some
of its sources and it gives Links at the
end if you want to dig in some more it's
really impressive actually it looks good
to me this is like a real product that's
going to ship to all over the world like
people everywhere in the next month or
two I think they said but this this
could only come from Bing right now like
the the more you use it the natural
language is super super impressive the
fact that it gives me a convincing
sounding couple of sentences in a row
and strings it together based on my
input super cool but the more you use it
the more you start to see these these
weird patterns and these habits and
these shortcomings again mostly in the
fact that
sometimes it's just going to be wrong a
little game I like to play is ask it a
question you already know the answer to
and then read what it says and spot the
error so I asked it right now okay what
are the best smartphone cameras right
now and it gave me s23 Ultra pixel 7 Pro
and iPhone 14 pro Max with this nice
little write-up with some specs for each
that's actually a pretty good list but
it is wrong about some of these numbers
here the s23 ultra has a 200 megapixel
camera and a 12 megapixel front-facing
camera but yeah okay it's mostly right I
then asked it what are the five best
electric vehicles out right now and it
gives me some five reasonable options
but I don't know I don't know any expert
that would put the Jaguar i-pace on
their list right now and leave the
rivian off like basically the answers
that it gives are really convincing to
someone who doesn't know anything
already about that subject but if you
are already an expert in the subject
that you ask it about then you'll find
that the answers are like C plus maybe B
plus sometimes at best so now you see
what's happening like now suddenly when
you're asking chat GPT or Bing about
like a factual thing or something you
need help with suddenly you also should
probably add these layers on top like am
I a complete noob in this topic that I'm
asking about am I just willing to
blindly trust whatever this spits out
without any further research is a B plus
answer gonna be good enough for me even
if it might have some possible errors in
it
you know that might be good enough for
just asking like you know how old a
cheetah gets or something like that but
maybe not good enough for planning a
trip or meal planning for someone with
an allergy or something like that and
then if you look around the internet
people have gotten it to give
increasingly more and more unhinged
answers over time as it tries to
simulate conversations and stay in the
flow with natural language I've seen
anywhere from arguing about simple
corrections to spewing weird stories
about how it's spied on its own
developers or how it wants to be
sentient to gaslighting people about
things and lying about his previous
answers and just saying some straight up
scary stuff just go to the Bing
subreddit for like an all-you-can-eat
helping of all the insane stuff that
Bing has said to just the people testing
it over the past couple weeks can you
imagine can you imagine if Google did
this if if Google search at the top of
search for people was just spewing out
random stories and misinformation and
like all kinds of insane unhinged things
that would not fly now to be fair this
version of Bing isn't out yet to the
public right so it is still a small
group testing phase but even with this
like Microsoft knew that some of it is
gonna get out there and potentially go
viral it feels like they even basically
programmed in lots of friendly emojis to
try to soften the blow so when it knows
it's giving an answer to maybe a more
controversial topic or something that it
doesn't have a super clear answer for
you might get a little smiley face at
the end just so you don't you know take
it too seriously also literally as of
today when I'm testing this it started
completely bailing on a lot of topics
that might just be the slightest bit
existential or dangerous it just says I
prefer not to continue this conversation
and then it just stops it just refuses
to answer any more questions on that
topic until you reset it which seems
like a pretty good Fail-Safe it's a
pretty good idea in hindsight but like
we've already seen the other stuff it's
gotten out there the damage has been
done like the point still stands this
could have only come from Bing like a
lot of people
might have forgotten about this or might
not have even known about this but
Google has been working on
conversational AI stuff for years we've
seen Google Assistant but they also
literally showed an AI chat bot demo on
stage at Google I O in 2021 where you
could have this whole conversation with
any person or object or anything in the
universe that you wanted their demo on
stage was asking Pluto about itself nice
and friendly right oh what's it like to
be you Pluto what would it feel like if
I visited you how do you feel so far
from the Sun the difference with Google
is this was never shipped as a product
like this was an internal research
project but the idea of displacing their
massive search and ads business with the
chat bot that gets things wrong all the
time is insane it's just it's not it
can't happen right so literally
searching ads is more than half of
Google's revenue as a company
that's what having everything to lose
looks like now to be fair Google did
hold an event in Paris the day after
Microsoft's event which was them talking
a little more about their chat with
search AI plans and they did say they're
planning on eventually doing a chat bot
on top of Google search It's called Bard
it was much more subdued though and yes
it also literally did have a factual
mistake in the promo for it so look I
actually like the idea I obviously think
it's smart when you're on the precipice
of this huge AI thing to have ai kind of
be this like co-pilot for the web to
like help you around the internet the
idea of it summarizing a longer piece
into some bullet points accurately is
that would be great like the fact that
it could give you spark notes for a
longer book you haven't read yet cool it
could even help you meal plan help you
plan a trip help you make a purchase
decision but it's it's clear that we're
still at the beginning of this like
there are there are so many unanswered
questions from obviously the fact
checking to like do school tools Embrace
this or ban this or like do search how
do search engines keep sending traffic
to the Publishers who are the sources
that the chatbot is scraping from I mean
you get The Links at the bottom but a
lot of people are not going to click
those anymore if you just give them the
answer above the search results so right
now in its current stage my take is
anything we do with any of these AI
tools should be a collaboration with the
human touch like you wouldn't you
wouldn't just put in a query in Dolly
and then just take whatever it generates
and put in a frame and just call that
art right it's more for inspiration for
your own paint and canvas like you
wouldn't ask Chad gbt to write an essay
and then just copy and paste it and
submit it as your own it's supposed to
be the inspiration for the framework for
your own piece for the own for the human
touch so of course you shouldn't ask the
Bing chat bot what TV you should buy and
then just like mindlessly click and buy
the first one that comes up I mean it
could be fine but it could also be a c
plus answer you should use that as a
springboard for your own more informed
research especially on topics that you
don't already know much about
like maybe don't just buy 19 backpacks
immediately when asking if it can fit in
the back of a Tesla maybe check its work
first
thanks for watching
catch you in the next one
peace
foreign
[Music]